.
2021, ONE FULL WEEK OF
PRESEASON ACTION IS NOW BEHIND
US.
IF YOU CAN WAIT, TRY TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
UP IN THE AIR RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL TRY AND TOUCH ON ALL OF
THAT.
BUT YOU'VE BEEN GETTING YOUR
QUESTIONS IN AND YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO DO THAT IN THE B/R
APP.
THAT IS A GOOD THING TO DO,
WRITE THEM DOWN, GET THEM IN
THERE.
I WILL BE ANSWERING THEM
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW AND FOR A
COUPLE MORE THURSDAYS HERE AT
1:00 P.M. EASTERN ON THE B/R
APPEAR.
YOUR FANTASY FIRE DRILL IS UNDER
WAY.
LET'S GET INTO IT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THIS TIME OF
YEAR WANT TO KNOW ABOUT SLEEPER.
WHO IS YOUR BIGGEST SLEEPER AT
TIGHT END?
IT'S GOING TO HELP A LOT OF YOU
WATCHING OUT THERE.
THE POSITION IS A BIT TOP HEAVY.
THERE'S SOME STRONG NAMES AT THE
TOP.
TRAVIS KELSEY AND GEORGE KALES
AND DARREN WALLER'S OF THE
WORLD.
WHO IS GOING TO MAKE THAT LEAP?
LET'S HEAD DOWN TO NEW ORLEANS.
ADAM TROUTMAN IS A NAME YOU NEED
TO BE LOOKING AT.
YOU SEE HIS ADP.
WAY OFF THE BOARD RIGHT NOW.
IN MORE HILL AND JARED COOK.
MICHAEL THOMAS, IS A COMPLETE
M.I.A. AND A TBD AS TO WHEN HE
WILL BE BACK.
SO ADAM TROUTMAN COULD BE A NAME
TO GET LATER ON IN YOUR DRAFT
WHO COMES THROUGH AS A POTENTIAL
TOP TEN OPTION AT THE POSITION.
TARGETS ARE GOING TO GO TO
CAMARA.
WHO ELSE IS GOING TO GET THEM?
I THINK TROUTMAN HAS A SHOT TO
EAT SOME OF THOSE UP IN HIS
SECOND YEAR.
ANOTHER QUESTION, BIGGEST
SLEEPER AT RUNNING BACK, LOOKING
AT GUS EDWARDS.
GUS EDWARDS IS NOT A BAD ONE.
THE RAVENS ARE WILLING TO KEEP
HIM IN THE MIX, EVEN WITH J.K.
DOBBINS.
BUT GUS EDWARDS, REGARDLESS OF
THE ROLE OF J.K. DOBBINS, I
THINK GUS EDWARDS WILL STILL
HAVE SOME FLEX APPEAL.
THIS IS A RUN FIRST OFFENSE.
THEY ARE MORE THAN WILLING TO
USE MULTIPLE RUNNING BACKS AND
EVEN LAMAR JACKSON IN THEIR RUN
FIRST OFFENSE.
SO I THINK DOBBINS WILL SEE THE
MOST TOUCHES.
I THINK AT MINIMUM, GUS EDWARDS
WILL BE A WEEKLY FLEX OPTION.
NOW, IF DOBBINS WERE TO GO DOWN
IN THIS OFFENSE, WELL, GUS
EDWARDS COULD LEAD THE WAY AND
END UP BEING AT MINIMUM A SOLID
RB2.
SO THAT IS A NAME I CAN THINK
OF.
WE'LL GET TO A COUPLE MORE HERE
IN JUST A BIT, BECAUSE YOU A TIN
JOHNSON IS KEEPING IT PRETTY
GENERAL.
AUSTIN SAYS WHO ARE THE BIGGEST
SLEEPERS THIS SEASON?
WE'LL HIT THIS A KUMP MORE
TIMES, A COUPLE MORE SHOWS TO
GO.
LET ME GIVE YOU A COUPLE MORE
RUNNING BACKS.
LET'S GO TO A TEAM THAT HAS AN
OFFENSE THAT YOU WANT A PIECE
OF.
THAT'S THE GREEN BAY PACKERS.
A.J. DILLON.
THE PACKERS HAVE AARON JONES.
AARON JONES IS GOING TO BE
PROBABLY GONE IN THE FIRST 10 OR
12 PICKS OF YOUR FANTASY DRAFT.
HOWEVER, BECAUSE IT IS A GREAT
TEAM AND WHEN IN DOUBT YOU WANT
A PIECE OF A GRIT OFFENSE, I
WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT ATE J.
DILLON.
AND YOU SEE THE ADP, BY THE WAY.
INSIDE THE TOP 100 FOR THE CLEAR
NUMBER 2 BACK IN GREEN BAY.
JAMAL WILLIAMS USED TO BE THE
NUMBER TWO TO AARON JONES.
AND HE HAD FANTASY VALUE.
EVEN WHEN JONES WAS HEALTHY.
BUT THE KEY TO ME, IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR A SLEEPER, WHEN
JONES WAS BANGED UP, MULLINS
COULD STEP IN THERE AND BE A TOP
15 RUNNING BACK.
I BELIEVE A.J. DILLON IS A FAR
MORE TALENTED PLAYER THAN JAMAL
WILL Y
WILLIAMS.
IF JONES WERE TO GO DOWN, YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A TOP RUNNING BACK IN
DILLON.
HE WENT FROM GREEN BAY TO
DETROIT AND JAMAL WILLIAMS, WE
HAVE SEEN IN PREVIOUS YEARS.
IF YOU HAVE AARON JONES, JAMAL
WILLIAMS HAS BEEN A THORN IN
YOUR SIDE.
I GET THAT.
BUT JAMAL WILLIAMS HAS PROVEN TO
BE A PROVEN AND RELIABLE FANTASY
COMMODITY.
DEANDRE IS GOING TO LEAD THE WAY
FOR DETROIT.
I THINK YOU KNOW THAT.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT
CLEAR OF A LEAD.
I THINK WE CAN BE IN A 1A, 1B
SITUATION, SIMILAR TO WHAT
WILLIAMS DID AT TIMES IN
PREVIOUS SEASONS.
AND DON'T FORGET, THIS WIDE
RECEIVER GROUP IN DETROIT MIGHT
BE ONE OF THE WORST IF NOT THE
WORST IN THE LEAGUE.
SO THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO RUN
THE BALL.
DAN CAMPBELL, FP FOOTBALL GUY IS
A HEAD COACH.
HE'S GOING WANT TO RUN THE
FOOTBALL.
I WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT JAMAL.
BY THE WAY, IF HE WOULD LEAD THE
WAY, YOU'RE LOOKING AT A SOLID
RB2.
SO THOSE ARE THE SLEEPERS.
THOSE ARE THE NAMES YOU'RE GOING
TO MAKE AN EFFORT TO GO GET.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE PLAYERS YOU
SHOULD BE AVOIDING?
I HAVE SOME NAMES I'M GOING TO
GET TO, BUT YOUR QUESTIONS FIRST
AND LET'S START WITH JAY DESSIO.
SHOULD I AVOID DARREL HENDERSON?
FEEL LIKE I SHOULD.
JAY DESSIO, YOU SHOULD NOT.
WITH CAM ACRES OUT FOR THE
SEASON DUE TO A TORN ACHILLES,
THIS IS DARREN HENDERSON'S
BACKFIELD.
THIS IS A PLAYER WHO WON YOU
FANTASY MATCHUPS AT TIMES.
TO ME, PRETTY SOLID.
HIS ADP PUTS HIM AROUND RB23 OFF
THE BOARD.
I HAVE HIM AT 20.
I THINK HE COULD BE A TOP 15
RUNNING BACK THIS YEAR BECAUSE
MATTHEW STAFFORD TAKES THE RAMS
OFFENSE TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
I THINK MATTHEW STAFFORD IS
GOING TO HELP THIS RAMS OFFENSE
UNLOCK THEIR TRUE POTENTIAL.
AND WITH DARREL HENDERSON
LEADING THE WAY, THAT'S SCORING
OPPORTUNITIES ONCE AGAIN.
WHEN IN DOUBT, GET A PIECE OF A
GOOD OFFENSE.
THIS COULD BE A GREAT OFFENSE
AND DARREL HENDERSON SHOULD BE
SOMEONE JAY DESSIO YOU SHOULD
NOT BE AVOIDING.
I'D BE TRYING TO GET DARREL
HENDERSON THIS YEAR.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ANOTHER
QUESTION HERE.
THINKING ABOUT AVOIDING MIKE
EVANS, GOOD IDEA.
OR BAD IDEA?
BAD IDEA.
NOW, LAST YEAR, MIKE EVANS
FINISHED THE SEASON AS WIDE
RECEIVER.
WE KNOW CHRIS WILL MISS SOME
TIME.
LOOK WHERE HE'S AT, THOUGH,
RIGHT NOW.
ADP OF 37.
12-TEAM LEAGUE, THAT'S THE TOP
OF THE FOURTH ROUND.
TO ME, HE'S WIDE RECEIVER 14.
THAT'S WHAT HIS ADP IS.
THAT'S WHERE I HAVE HIM RANKED.
HE FINISHED AS WIDE RECEIVER 10.
SO YOU ALREADY HAVE THE
REGRESSION, WHICH IS FAIR TO
EXPECT, BUILD IN FOR MIKE EVANS.
IN FACT, HIS VALUE HAS DROPPED A
BIT.
HE'S STILL IN A GREAT OFFENSE,
EVEN WITH GODWIN BACK.
THE OPPORTUNITIES WILL BE THERE
AND SCORING OPPORTUNITIES WILL
BE THERE.
YOU DON'T LIKE TO RELY ON
TOUCHDOWNS, BUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES WILL BE THERE FOR
MIKE EVANS.
WE KNOW HE'S A GREAT RED ZONE
THREAT, AS WELL.
HE IS SOMEONE I WOULD BE LOOKING
TO GET AND NOT AVOID.
RYAN FITZPATRICK THERE NOW, I'M
GOING TO SAY RELIABLE AND MUCH
LIKE MIKE EVANS, WHILE NOT A
SUPERSTAR PLAYER, YOU SEE THE
NUMBERS LAST YEAR FOR LOGAN
THOMAS.
HIS ADP, 97.7.
CERTAINLY NOT EXPENSIVE HAS HIM
AROUND THE NINTH TIGHT END OFF
THE BOARD.
SO DO I.
BUT LAST YEAR, HE FINISHED AS
THE SIXTH BEST TIGHT END.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY FOR THE
NUMBERS HE PUT UP LAST SEASON.
IN FACT, THAT REGRESSION IS IN
THERE A LITTLE BIT.
CURTIS SAMUEL, JUST GETTING OFF
THE PUP LIST.
LOGAN THOMAS IS NOT AN EXCITING
NAME.
IS HE GOING TO WIN YOU WEEKS
LIKE A TRAVIS KELSEY?
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT RELIABILITY AT TIGHT END
COULD BE A PREMIUM.
SO YOU TRY TO GO AND GET LOGAN
THOMAS.
WHAT ABOUT SOME PLAYERS I'M
LOOKING TO AVOID?
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN
REVISIT.
I WANT TO START WITH A NAME
THAT'S COMING UPMENTS IN THE
NEWS, ON THIS SHOW, LAST WEEK,
THIS WEEK, MICHAEL THOMAS,
SAINTS WIDE RECEIVER.
WELL, THAT'S NICE THAT HE'S
LISTED AS A SAINTS WIDE
RECEIVER, BUT HE'S NOT THE
NUMBER ONE GUY THAT WE KNOW OF.
IN FACT, WE DON'T KNOW WHEN HE'S
GOING TO BE BACK ON THE FIELD.
THE DELAY AND THE SURGERY, THE
LACK OF COMMUNICATION WITH THE
TEAM, THESE ARE ALL RED FLAGS TO
MEAN DREW BREES NOT BEING THE
QUARTERBACK OF THIS TEAM ANY
MORE.
ALL OF THIS IS BAD, YET, YOU SEE
THE ADP.
63.3.
WE'RE TALKING HERE, YOU KNOW,
FIFTH ROUND, SIXTH ROUND.
AND EVEN STILL, THAT'S THE 27th
WIDE RECEIVER OFF THE BOARD.
HE'S MY WIDE RECEIVER 46.
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THIS GUY IS
GETTING ON THE FIELD.
THEY ARE NOT AS GOOD AS THEY
WERE LAST YEAR.
EVEN WHEN HE GETS ON THE FIELD,
HE'S NOT GOING TO HAVE A NORMAL
OFF SEASON.
HE'S GOING TO NEED SOME TIME TO
GET UP TO SPEED.
I DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO PAY A
PREMIUM FOR ADP.
DO NOT PAY FOR NAME VALUE.
ASSESS THE SITUATION.
LET'S GO TO ANOTHER PLAYER I
LIKE AS A TALENT, BUT THE
SITUATION AND THE VOLUME
CONCERNS ME.
WE GO OUT WEST TO VEGAS AND
LET'S TALK ABOUT JOSH JACOBS FOR
THE LAS VEGAS RAIDERS.
THE NUMBERS LAST YEAR, VERY
SOLID.
YOU SEE HIS ADP, AROUND 28.3.
THAT'S ABOUT THE 17th RUNNING
BACK OFF THE BOARD.
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE RB2
TIER.
THAT'S FINE.
BUT TO ME, HE'S A LITTLE BIT
LOWER.
HE'S MORE ON THE BACK END OF THE
RB2 TIER.
RB21.
WHY IS THAT?
TWO REASONS.
NUMBER ONE, MUCH TO OUR CHAGRIN,
THEY SIGNED KENYON DPRAI DRAKE.
YOU KNOW HE CAN CONTRIBUTE AND
YOU CAN CONTRIBUTE WHERE JOSH
JACOBS HASN'T BEEN CALLED UPON.
BECAUSE HIS POTENTIAL AND HIS
FANTASY NUMBERS ARE LIMITED BY
THE FACT THAT HE'S NOT INVOLVED
THAT MUCH IN THE PASSING GAME.
THAT'S BEEN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
AND THEN THEY BRING KENYON DRAKE
WHO CAN HANDLE A LOT OF THAT
ROLE.
I THINK RIGHT NOW, NOT A
COMPLETE AVOID, BUT AT HIS
CURRENT PRICE TAG, I HAVE TO SAY
JOSH JACOBS NOT WORTH IT WHERE
IT'S GOING BECAUSE OF THE
PRESENCE OF KENYON GREAT LAKE.
AND ONE MORE THAT CAME UP, THIS
IS SOMEONE PEOPLE WERE HOPING TO
GO GET WITH UPSIDE, MILES
GASKET, RDP 47th OVERALL.
I MOVED HIM DOWN TO 29.
BRIAN FLORES IN MIAMI TALKING
ABOUT A FREE BACK ROTATION AND
USING GASKET IN SITUATIONAL
SPOTS, THAT DOES NOT MAKE ME
FEEL GOOD.
THERE ARE NO DEFINITIVE
STATEMENTS.
LET'S GET A LITTLE DEEPER IN
INJURIES.
THIS IS A BIG ONE.
THIS IS FROM CONTAINARE322.
SHOULD WE BE CONCERNED ABOUT
STEPHON DIGS?
WHY DO YOU SEE HIM LANDING
COMPARED TO OTHER WIDE
RECEIVERS?
I'LL GIVE YOU MY TOP FIVE WIDE
RECEIVERS COMING UP A LITTLE
LATER.
STEPHON DIGS MAY APPEAR THERE.
HOWEVER, WE DID HEAR EARLIER
THIS WEEK FROM HEAD COACH SEAN
McDERMOTT OF THE BUFFALO BILLS
THAT THIS KNEE ISSUE TONS BE
STICKING AROUND.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF AUGUST.
WE'VE ONLY HAD ONE PRESEASON
GAME.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THIS IS A TEAM THAT THINKS
THEY CAN GO TO THE SUPER BOWL
AND THEY HAVE FAIR EXPECTATIONS
TO DO SO.
NOW THERE'S A KNEE ISSUE.
IT'S JUST THE SITUATION TO KEEP
AN EYE ON IF YOU'RE DRAFTING IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
MAYBE YOU LOOK SOMEWHERE ELSE
INSTEAD OF STEPHON DIGS, JUST TO
BE SAFE.
WE'RE JUST IN THE EXTRA CAUTIOUS
MODE RIGHT NOW.
DRAFT, DONE, THIS SEASON IS OVER
AND YOU MOVE ON.
DYNASTY LEAGUES, YOU'RE GOING TO
KEEP SOMEONE AROUND WHO MIGHT BE
INJURED.
IF RIGHT NOW YOU LOOK AT YOUR
DYNASTY LEAGUE ROSTER AND SAY
I'M HURTING, I PROBABLY WON'T
CONTEND HE THIS SEASON.
MAYBE YOU LOOK TO TRADE A
MICHAEL THOMAS WHO CAN WEATHER
THAT STORM WHERE YOU MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO DO SO AND THEN THEY CAN
TAKE ON THAT RISK.
IF YOU'RE NOT A VERY GOOD TEAM
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE HE'S SUCH A
BIG QUESTION MARK IN A DYNASTY
LEAGUE, I MIGHT BE LOOKING TO
SHOP HIM.
AND THAT RED COLOR NOR THAT
ANKLE ENGINEER IS RIGHT ON FOR
MICHAEL THOMAS.
I HAVE NOTHING POSITIVE TO SAY
ABOUT HIM.
ADAM ASKED, SHOULD I SHOULD I
KEEP WALLACE?
HE'S BEEN A LITTLE BANGED UP.
NOTHING TO REALLY WORRY ABOUT
HERE.
HE'S A TRUE STUD AT HIS
POSITION.
WE TALKED ABOUT JAMAL WILL YAMTS
EARLIER.
AR
I CAN'T GET SUPER EXCITED ABOUT
SWIFT.
BOTH GUYS A LITTLE BANGED UP
HERE.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE WIDE
RECEIVER POSITION.
YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO MY TOP
FIVE WIDE RECEIVERS.
HE SAYS THOUGHTS ON DEONTE.
LET'S START WITH THE RUNNING
BACKS THERE BECAUSE THAT'S TREE
OF MY TOP 13 RUNNING BACKS.
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO GO RIGHT
THERE, THEORETICALLY, TWO NUMBER
ONES AND SOMEONE RIGHT AT THE
RB1, RB2 TIER, THEN YOU'RE AHEAD
OF THE GAME.
JOHNSON, WIDE RECEIVER 21 TO ME,
61.3.
ADJACENT CLAYPOOL IN MY TOP 30.
THAT IS THREE STEELERS IN MY TOP
36 AT WIDE RECEIVER.
JOHNSON, A FINE RECEIVER, TOO,
BUT WITH THE OTHERS, IT WILL BE
TOUGH FOR HIM TO HIT HIS CEILING
OFTEN.
I WOULD SAY THE SAME FOR D.J.
MOORE.
I THINK HE'S A FINE WIDE
RECEIVER.
BUT DJ MOORE, I THINK, IS THE
CLEAR GUY FOR THE CAROLINA
PANTHERS.
WHEREAS DEONTE JOHNSON ON A
BETTER TEAM HAS MORE COMPETITION
FOR TARGET.
SO I THINK YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF
WIDE RECEIVER TWOS HERE.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE SUPER
UPSIDE BECAUSE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON AROUND THEM.
BUT AT THE SAME TOKEN, YOU HAVE
THREE OF MY TOP TEN RUNNING
BACKS.
SO I THINK IT WORKED OUT OKAY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE THE
POINTS COMING FROM.
SOMETIMES YOU'RE STACKED MORE AT
ONE POSITION THAN ANOTHER.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE
HERE.
THIS COMES FROM DOUGLAS.
I NEED TO KEEP TWO STANDARD
SCORING.
DOBBINS, WALLACE, JEFFERSON IN
THE 13th, METCALFE IN THE 15th.
IS IT CRAZY TO KEEP TWO WIDE
RECEIVERS?
IT IS NOT CRAZY AT ALL.
UNBELIEVABLE VALUES HERE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO PLAYERS
THAT WILL BE GONE INSIDE THE TOP
20 AND INSIDE THE TOP 15 PICKS
AND YOU'RE KEEPING THEM IN THROW
AWAY ROUNDS?
YES, YOU'RE STARTING WITH TWO
WIDE RECEIVERS, BUT YOU'RE
GETTING TWO BONA FIDE WIDE
RECEIVER ONES.
METCALFE IS PROBABLY SAFE.
JEFFERSON I THINK IS A VALUE AT
24 RIGHT NOW FOR THE MINNESOTA
VIKINGS.
I LOVE THIS.
BY THE WAY, KEEPING TWO GUYS
LIKE THIS MEANS NOW YOU CAN
FOCUS ON THE RUNNING BACK
POSITION.
YOU KNOW, IF IT IS BEST PLAYER
AVAILABLE AND YOU STILL SEE A
WIDE RECEIVER YOU LIKE, THAT'S
FINE.
BUT YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY SET AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THE BIG
ADVANTAGE WITH THESE TWO GUYS AT
THE TOP OF YOUR PERSONAL DEPTH
CHART.
LET'S MOVE ON HERE.
LET'S SEE.
CHAD SAYS IF I TAKE DERRICK
HENRY AT 3, A.J. BROWN WAS
THERE.
DO I TAKE HIM OR JUSTIN
JEFFERSON?
HERE IS WHAT I'LL TELL YOU.
I HAVE JUSTIN JEFFERSON ONE SPOT
HIGHER THAN AJ BROWN.
SO RIGHT THERE ALONE, I'M GOING
TO TELL YOU TO TAKE JUSTIN
JEFFERSON.
HOWEVER, IT'S GOOD TO HAVE SOME
VARIANCE IF YOU CAN.
THIS IS A TIEBREAKER SITUATION,
RIGHT?
JEFFERSON, BROWN, BACK TO BACK
FOR ME, MAYBE YOURSELF IN
RANKINGS.
BUT IF YOU HAVE DERRICK HENRY,
GET A LITTLE VARIANCE THERE.
YOU GET JUSTIN JEFFERSON AND
DON'T FORGET, WITH AJ BROWN,
GREAT, AMAZING, TALENTED
PLAYERS, BUT THEY DID ADD JULIO
JONES.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME VOLUME
AWAY FROM HIM AND DERRICK HENRY
IS A RUNNING MACHINE.
.THEY'RE STILL GOING TO RELY ON
HIM.
I GO JUSTIN JEFFERSON BASICALLY
TO GET YOU SOME VARIANCE, GET
YOU AWAY FROM BEING TOO
TENNESSEE TITAN HEAVY.
I HAD JAMES WHITE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER, NOT EXACTLY AN
ESTABLISHED GROUP OF RECEIVERS
OR REALLY ANYBODY THERE.
JAMES WHITE IS KIND OF BOAR ING.
HE'S GOING TO CATCH PASSES
THERE.
YOU HAVE NEW FACES AT THE TIGHT
END.
IT'S NOT A GREAT TEAM.
WHO KNOWS WHO IS GOING TO BE
PLAYING QUARTERBACK BY THE END
OF THAT SEASON.
BUT JAMES WHITE IS KIND OF SAFE.
HE'S A STASH GUY AND EITHER ONE
OF THESE PLAYERS.
IF YOU GET A COUPLE OF WEEKS IN
THE SEASON AND SAY I'VE GOT
INJURIES, I'VE GOT TO UPGRADE
ANOTHER POSITION, YOU'RE GOING
TO CUT THESE GUYS LOOSE AND
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MISS THEM.
JAMES WHILE WILL BE THE TYPE OF
PLAYER THAT ENDS UP ON 8 OF THE
12 TEAMS THIS YEAR.
HE WILL CATCH SIX PASSES IN THE
GAME, PICK THEM UP, THEN HE'LL
CATCH TWO.
I WOULD STASH AWAY HIM BECAUSE
WHEN IN DOUBT, THE PATRIOTS
WILL, INDEED, DUMP IT OFF TO
HIM.
NOW, TALK ABOUT MY TOP WIDE
RECEIVER FOR THE SEASON.
I DID BRING UP A NAME THAT IS
GOING TO APPEAR IN THIS LIST.
I'M GOING TO START WITH DeVONTE
ADAMS.
IT HELPS THAT AARON RODGERS CAME
BACK.
DeVONTE ADAMS, STEPHON DIXON.
IF YOU'RE DRAFTING THIS WEEKEND,
YOU MIGHT SAY I DON'T WANT TO DO
THIS.
I'M GOING TO TAKE DeVONTE ADAMS,
TYREKE HILL, CALVIN RIDLEY
ROUNDS OUT MY TOP FIVE.
THESE ARE MY TOP FIVE WIDE
RECEIVES, BUT YOU SAW NAMES
EARLIER LIKE JUSTIN JEFFERSON
WHO I THINK WILL BE WIDE REC
E
RECEIVER ONES.
HOW ABOUT ALLEN ROBINSON.
THIS IS MY TOP FIVE GROUP.
LIKE I SAID, HE'S THE ONLY ONE
THAT HAS A BIT OF A QUESTION
MARK RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THIS KNEE
ISSUE SEEMS TO BE LINGERING A
LITTLE BIT LONGER.
AND YOU WOULD WANT TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH.
SO LET'S JUST KEEP AN EYE ON
THAT SITUATION.
IF YOU'RE DRAFTING AT THE END OF
THE MONTH, DIXON WILL BE FINE BY
THEN, YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
BUT CERTAINLY, AS YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT MY RANKINGS, A LOT MORE
HIGH ENGT DEPTH AT THE WIDE
RECEIVER POSITION THIS SEASON.
AS WE BEGIN TO WRAP THINGS UP
HERE, IT'S TIME FOR YOUR BURNING
QUESTIONS, WHETHER YOU'RE
WATCHING GAMES THIS PRESEASON
ALREADY, WHETHER YOU'RE KIND OF
PUTTING THINGS TOGETHER,
CATCHING UP, IS THIS THE YEAR
MIXON FINALLY GOES OFF OR IS HIS
OFFENSE A 0-2 LIMITING?
>> I THINK IT'S WRONG TO SAY HE
HASN'T GONE OFF YET.
TWO YEARS AGO, THE BENGALS WERE
AWFUL AND JOE MIBLGXON WAS GREA.
LAST YEAR, HE LOOKED BETTER.
THE RBO LINES FOR ME ARE FAIR.
I THINK HE'LL FIND A BIGGER ROLE
IN THE PASSING GAME.
JOE MIXON IS THE MOST
ESTABLISHED PLAYER THERE.
GO OFF, I DON'T THINK HE'S GOING
TO BLOW UP THIS SEASON, BUT I
THINK HE'LL FINISH INSIDE THE
TOP 12 AT THE RUNNING BACK
POSITION.
MA HOMES ACTUALLY FINISHED
SLIGHTLY HIGHER THAN JOSH ALLEN.
HERE IS WHAT I'LL SAY ABOUT
THIS.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO WRONG
EITHER WAY.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
FROM A VALUE STANDPOINT, THERE'S
NO WAY I'M TAKING ANY
QUARTERBACK THAT HIGH.
WHETHER IT BE MA HOMES AT 15 OR
27 FOR JOSH ALLEN.
IT'S NOT A POSITION I'M GOING TO
TAKE THAT HIGH.
IT'S NOT NECESSARY.
WHEN IN DOUBT, LOOK FOR LEGS.
HIGHER END WEAPONS FOR PATRICK
MA HOMES VERSUS JOSH HALLEN.
AK10 TO SAQUON OR TO NOT SAQUON.
THAT IS THE QUESTION BUT I
HAVEN'T GOTTEN IT THAT MUCH.
HE HAD A TORN ACL.
DANIEL JONES, IS HE GOING TO
MAKE THE JUMP THIS SEASON?
THAT IS THE BIG QUESTION FOR THE
NEW YORK GIANTS.
WE ADD KENNY HOLIDAY TO THE MIX.
BUT SAQUON BARKLEY IS READY TO
GO.
THIS IS NOT 10, 15 YEARS AGO
WHEN YOU NEED AN EXTRA YEAR TO
BOUNCE BACK FROM A TORN ACL.
WE'VE SEEN PLENTY OF SITUATIONS
WHERE A GUY CAN DO IT AND
PERFORM AT A HIGH LEVEL.
SO YES, I AM IN ON SAQUON
BARKLEY.
ALTHOUGH HE IS JUST OUTSIDE OF
MY TOP FIVE AT THE RUNNING BACK
POSITION.
DO I WANT TO GO ALL IN ON JAY
LYNN HURTS?
THAT ANSWER IS GOING TO BE NO.
I'LL SAY THIS.
THERE'S UP SIDE HERE.
I THINK EE BE BETTER IN FANTASY
VERSUS REALITY.
BUT THERE'S AN UNPROVEN NATURE
HERE ON A YOUNG TEAM.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE SOME
VARIANCE AT THE QUARTERBACK
POSITION.
MURRAY, WHEN EVERYBODY EXPECTED
HIM TO MAKE THE JUMP, I
UNDERSTOOD THERE THAT.
EVEN IF YOU THINK HE'S GOING TO
BE A SOLID FANTASY REQUESTING
THIS SEASON, THERE'S ENOUGH
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM THAT YOU
WOULDN'T GO ALL IN ON SOMEONE
LIKE JAYLYNN HURTS.
THE ONE PLAYER WHO I LIKE AS A
TALENT IS JONATHAN TAYLOR OF THE
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS RIGHT NOW.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE A BETTER FEEL
FOR THE INJURIES ON HIS O-LINE
WITH CARSON WENTZ.
I WANT TO HAVE BETTER VIBES
ABOUT THE TEAM AS A WHOLE.
WHEN IN DOUBT, I THINK YOU SHY
AWAY FROM BAD TEAMS.
THE NUMBERS WERE GOOD LAST YEAR.
HIS ADP OF 8.3 IS JUST A LITTLE
BIT TOO HIGH.
I'LL TELL YOU THIS, JONATHAN
TAYLOR IS THE ONLY INDIANAPOLIS
COLT IN MY TOP 100 OVERALL
RANKINGS.
THAT IS TELLING ON ITS OWN.
THAT TELLS ME THAT THE TEAM IS
NOT VERY EXCITING OR NOT VERY
GOOD AND I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE
THAT HAS THEM RANKED
ACCORDINGLY.
I LIKE JONATHAN TAYLOR AS A
PLAYER.
I'D LIKE TO FEEL BETTER ABOUT
THEIR SITUATION.
BECAUSE I DON'T, THAT ADP AROUND
8, 9 IS A BIT TOO STRONG.
HE WOULD BE THE RISKIEST PLAYER
TO ME INSIDE THE TOP 15.
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO MORE OF
YOUR QUESTIONS RIGHT HERE ON
YOUR FANTASY FIRE DRILL.
FIRE THEM IN THERE AS YOU'RE
WATCHING THE GAMES.
PUT THEM IN THERE.
I'LL BE ANSWERING THEM.
GET THEM IN THE B/R APP AND I'LL
BE BACK HERE WITH YOU FOR THE
NEXT TWO THURSDAYS FOR YOUR
FANTASY FIRE DRILL AS WE LEAD
TOWARDS THE CHAMPIONSHIP 2021.
I'M MATT CAMP.
THANKS FOR WATCHING.